800 colonnes de près de deux mètres de
long représente les trois 1959
hommes femmes et enfants afro-américains
lyncher aux états unis après la guerre
civile et l'abolition de l'esclavagé en
ils ont été recensés par l'omg ecall
justice initiative qui veut s'attaquer à
l'injustice raciale et économique
ces lynchages ne figure pas dans les
livres d'histoire et pourtant à l'époque
des foules nombreuses d'hommes femmes et
enfants assistaient à ces exécutions
publiques illégales et impunies elles
ont été photographiées utilisé comme
carte postale
les victimes étaient pendus ou criblés
de balles brûlé parfois après avoir été
torturé
[Musique]
la chanteuse billie holliday a
immortalisé cette sinistre pratique dans
une mélodie célèbre strain chaude et
joséphine michael avait 5 ans quand son
père a été lynché dans le comté de
lansdowne alabama criblé de balles par
un groupe de blancs mon père a été tué
parce qu'il était un homme d'affaires
noir prospère dit elle est abandonnée
dans un fossé au bord de la route
son nom se retrouve sur une des colonnes
du monument de montgomery de nombreux
blancs du sud esclavagiste se sont
opposés à l'émancipation ou vote des
noirs
les lynchages étaient plus nombreux
pendant les crises économiques des
militants blanc en faveur des droits
civils ont également été lâchés on peut
pas comprendre le lynchage sans
comprendre l'esclavagé le fondateur de
l'omg
l'économie de montgomery dépendait de l'
esclavage les deux tiers de ses
habitants étaient des esclaves
la ville était un marché d'esclaves le
dernier lynchage a été recensé à mobile
en alabama en 1981 m'accorde en ondes a
été pendu par trois membres du ku klux
klan l'un d'entre eux a été condamné à
mort exécuté
jean michel leprince radio canada
montréal